so for the last eight months
this crisis has been mismanaged in a way
that no crisis in our recent history has
ever been
but you know who did it you know who's
at fault you know who we're blaming
you yesterday new york's governor andrew
cuomo explain
just how culpable you really are for
this disaster
we will make mistakes in life
we try not to but we do the key
is to be strong and secure enough to
admit your mistakes and admit your
shortcomings don't get defensive
denying the mistake only assures
repeating the mistake
we have made mistakes during covet i
wrote a book on the lessons to be
learned from the covet crisis
admit your mistakes says the thinnest
skin
politician in american history a man who
is constitutionally incapable of
admitting his own mistakes ask anyone
who knows the governor of new york
admit your mistakes
self-awareness has died along with a lot
of people
in new york state at the same time tony
fauci is telling us that mass may be
necessary
forever even after we have a coronavirus
vaccine